color it's close mine's a little bit
more um uh
a lot louder than yours yeah mine's
louder than you yeah are you dating now
god wanted me to shine a little bit are
you dating now and i'm married but i can
start dating if you'd like me to
just is your wife uh redhead no god no
we would never right tell we would never
our kind don't we don't uh we don't mate
that's like incestual it's just
repulsive
yeah we would never
it's not that she's not attractive or
it's just we don't we know it's in turn
a lot we know we're born with the
knowledge to not
have interaction with my only reference
to what you're saying is lucy and ricky
i have no idea like well ask caroline
would caroline date another redhead she
would not i'll ask i'll answer for her
right right i feel like i would put
maybe like i feel like a lot of guys
have like red beards too yeah but that's
different pirates that's different those
are pirates are redbeard right yeah
those are the men that sail the seas no
you would never did you might you might
hook up or hang out with a redhead but
you would never like be in a serious
relationship with one yeah because then
you'd look like twins everywhere it's
weird then people think you're related
yeah
the assumption is that we're always
related no i get what you're saying
because and i'm happily married but i
would never date another bald woman why
not
because we know each other and it's just
for the same all the same reasons that
you just went i wouldn't assume that you
and another bald woman are related
i just think you're on the same path
maybe you're connecting that's like the
closest you can get she's bald you're
bald
that's a big thing in common when you're
both bald yeah that's pretty great
you save money on shampoo
you're right you can share hats assuming
you have the same size dome
wow it's got to be nice to shave each
other's heads i mean you bick it don't
you bick it
bicket like a bic razor you pick it
that's what we call it bick in it that's
what we call it who yeah who are we
i don't know the red community we call
it bick in it bicket we talk about
people without red hair
you know we call them we have names i
don't want to get into it but we call
you people with your color hair i have
no hair
yeah i know what you when you did you
had it or jackie you know we call her a
name but i'm not going to say what are
you calling my daughter no i want to
know it's bad it's she'll tell you tell
her tell what do we call people with not
red hair caroline
i'm going to let andrew answer this
andrew
losers no what
he doesn't know no it's it's it's a rude
word
[Music]